moving on in this morning's money watch
the newest inflation numbers have just
come out they're starting to show the
impact of falling gas prices the
consumer price index shows prices rose
eight and a half percent in july
compared to a year ago this follows
june's inflation rate of 9.1 percent
which was the highest in more than 40
years the national average of a price of
for a gallon of gas has fallen nearly 70
cents just over the past month cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger is
here to help us break this all down jill
good morning 8.5
that's a significant reduction yeah it
may be that inflation peaked in the
month of june because these july numbers
are somewhat better than expected not
fantastic news yet but we were thinking
8.7 percent on an annualized basis eight
and a half is good the other part of
this report that you as you mentioned
gas and energy prices that pushes the
numbers down pretty dramatically and if
we look at the gas index for example
down 7.7
over the last month obviously right
since gas peaked in june we're down a
dollar a gallon since then but when you
look at the year over year and you want
to know why people are still complaining
that gas index is still up 44
when we pull out gas and all energy as
well as food the rest of the inflation
picture is still simmering so we really
have to pay attention to that
specifically shelter which continues to
be a big driver of inflation so how will
we know that prices have peaked i mean
what's the guarantee that they won't
just go back up next month well i think
that's a great question because the war
in ukraine is the real unknown that was
what pushed oil prices above 120 a
barrel now we're back at 90. food prices
also increase because so much of the
bread basket of europe is derived from
ukraine i think that if the war does not
create another real shortage that we
could believe that over the next few
months we have seen the peak the end of
the year we should come down towards
seven maybe six percent but just
remember gang before we started this
inflationary period the inflation rate
in the united states was just under two
percent so these are big changes what
does it mean for a potential recession
well i mean look when we have high
periods of inflation and the federal
reserve is actively fighting that
inflation by raising interest rates
those are the conditions that usually
will lead to this broad slowdown called
a recession it does not appear we're in
a recession right this moment i mean
frankly we had a half a million jobs
created in the last month and an economy
that can create a half a million jobs is
not usually one that is classically in a
recession so i think that maybe for
another month we're going to sort of put
that recession talk off to the table
half a million jobs created but on the
flip side unemployment is now at more
than a 50-year low now what does that
mean
when it comes to the inflation rate i'll
tell you what's interesting about the
story of the labor market and that is
wages wages have been going up at a
pretty good clip so
5.2
from a year ago and businesses are
saying we have to pay more and that's
hard it's why it's hard to hire folks
but that wage component to me is very
important because when you think about
5.2
of a wage gain but inflation's at eight
and a half percent there's a gas
so people are falling behind does this
drop in the inflation rate mean that the
fed's interest rate hikes are working
and what does it mean for future hikes
well i mean yes and no i think that it
is that is clear that the fed's rate
hikes are probably having an impact on
the overall economy what's a bigger
impact right now on these numbers has to
be energy and food and that's probably
more war related so i think in the
months ahead the fed is going to keep
raising rates and i think that they are
going to have to because all those other
items without food and energy are still
high and the fed is probably going to go
a half or three quarters now still on
our way out here one last question what
is going on with credit card debt
well you know that gap that we talked
about where someone's making uh let's
say 5.2 more than last year but
everything cost eight and a half percent
more this year well guess what first
people start spending down their savings
people had a lot of savings during covid
there were stimulus checks there was
excess unemployment insurance there was
child tax credit so they built up
savings they've spent those savings down
but now we know once those savings are
down credit card debt has increased
ballooned credit card balances are up 13
from a year ago that is the biggest
annual pace in more than two decades and
just to be clear who's borrowing the
most the people you would imagine young
people they don't have savings built up
right and people who already have low
credit scores so we've got to keep an
eye on that because as the economy does
slow down those folks are still going to
be struggling with those credit card
balances wow so it's not just you at
home if you've got that credit card bill
going up all right jill slesner thank
you very much we appreciate it